[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to ask mkbhdv30
actually so it's a new month it's july
we have justine at the studio welcome hi
this is so exciting yeah so i mean we
haven't really changed the format at all
we asked you guys what you wanted to
know on twitter you guys asked a bunch
of questions and for both of us this is
the best of that yeah there's a lot of
questions tyler says i hate school
what's a good way to be successful i
want to be a software developer
okay that's a that took a nice positive
swing that's never really a problem you
can go online there are tutorials i
learned a lot of things that i didn't
learn in school on youtube so that's one
way of just figuring out if you're good
at it or not for sure i feel like you if
you want to be something like there's
nothing that is stopping you except
yourself if you want to be whatever it
is you can find anything online which i
mean we're talking to people who that's
basically all of our lives
so i think whatever you want to be you
can be it so be a software developer go
for it tyler yeah should we
answer the question of what are our
thoughts on the new refreshed macbooks
sure okay basically it's a spec bump
plus a slightly new keyboard i don't
know if you had any issues with the
previous keyboard i didn't i had a very
little bit with like the space bar and
the tab key but then i would just kind
of like
and it would just stick towards yeah so
it's a minor it's a minor update but
that's part of the thing is when people
go mobile uh you don't really see a big
difference until you get to the high end
which is the maxed out there's now a six
core 15 inch macbook pro with up to four
terabytes of internal storage 32 gigs of
ram
uh it's a beast and the reason people
will be going for that one is because
they push it to the limit kind of like
how they would a desktop but they need
to be mobile for sure i mean i edit
almost all of my videos on the go like
in hotel rooms or wherever i am like
you edit on a macbook pro yes yeah
that's really hard for me to do really
so that well you're editing a little bit
higher quality but everything i do add
it is at least 4k so it is it's a little
bit so you have a struggle you'll
probably benefit from the higher end for
sure you've upgraded i did okay yes
because i have the previous one which
was completely maxed out so even then
it's like those fans just start running
in the middle of the night when i'm
exporting videos so i'm excited to do
sort of side-by-side comparison i have a
question yes do you when you edit with
your macbook pro do you are you always
plugged in or do you ever edit on
battery power i sometimes on planes edit
on battery power okay
even when i'm on the plane i plug in to
edit on on power well if i can plug in i
will always but sometimes southwest
there's no outlets
you just have to edit but editing on a
plane is so weird because everybody is
watching you it's very weird to yeah
i've had editing yourself i was coming
back from wwdc and this one guy's like
hey i saw you editing some stuff about
the apple watch what do you think and it
was just showing like some of the screen
captures yeah and then i'm starting to
have a conversation and it's just it
gets weird but it's it's a thing it's a
struggle you guys should try it but
either way i definitely bought one of
the macbooks and i am quite excited
about it shouldn't i sheep views on
apple products be taken seriously
yeah that's actually a good thing
because when there's something that i
don't like i'm pretty vocal about it
when okay when justine has a complaint
about an apple product
you know it's real yeah because it comes
from here
and it's probably something that a lot
of people who use apple products have
experienced so you should take someone
who uses apple products opinion about
apple products seriously yeah and i mean
obviously i'm a huge fan so that i may
be a little biased but again if i have
an issue then it's an issue here's the
thing about bias i've talked about
before i have no problem with bias if
you calibrate yourself to another
person's bias then you can enjoy and
learn from all kinds of videos that's a
really good point yeah so bias i have it
you have it they have it they don't even
think they have it sometimes but they do
they do telling you you do so yeah not a
problem oh here's one i mean people have
asked about this i'm sure a lot but what
are your thoughts on igtv if you could
give your your 30 seconds of thoughts on
igtv i actually really enjoy editing
vertical video but the problem is i feel
like people are just repurposing old
content which i was also doing because i
already had it i just feel like
it's i don't know i don't want to watch
long-form vertical content yeah i love
stories it's tough for me to find
something i've thought about what's the
sweet spot for a length of an igtv video
i think it's like 90 seconds yeah yeah
even longer than a minute because i just
feel like i'm like okay cool what's next
do you ever turn your camera sideways to
shoot in
vertical
what do you mean so like uh your iphone
obviously turning this vertical but
turning like a i refuse okay that's i
can't do it i can't go there but what
i've been doing is just shooting with a
wider angle lens so that there is more
field of view so it's not as cropped in
if you've ever tried to crop in on a
normal video and realize just how tall a
9x16 is it's tough so you got it you got
to think about that do you think apple
will continue to remain relevant in the
smartphone game or will a new or
existing company take their market share
take their market trip everyone's trying
to take apple's market share yeah uh
it'll be a long time before i think
these are word relevant it'll be a long
time before apple's not
relevant yeah they are currently huge
it's just it is a completely different
thing like there are so many different
smartphones that are on android and this
is really the only one on ios that's so
true everyone i talked about the
ecosystem a while back if you ever want
to knock apple off its
relevance you can't just make a better
phone you have to make a better
experience and that involves a lot more
than just the phone it really is an
experience and i mean i'm still a huge
homepod fan because obviously i'm i'm
the number one apple fan girl so i i
hate it on it pretty hard what do you
like about the homepod though it sounds
really good it does it sounds really
really good and i have one in
well not like every room would have on
my office i do have one in my bathroom
just why not i want another weather
sometimes you know then i have one
downstairs and then one like in my
living room so it is now that you can
actually use all of them that's yeah it
sounds great in the stereo did you try
the stereo i haven't tried it yet
although i do own two they're in
different rooms
get them together you need to try it
because i was actually surprised that
i'll give a shot it sounds really good
it does sound great and i also have a
lot of alexas
yeah now you can say there's none in
here okay yeah but they might have them
true never mind sorry
waffles are pancakes
oh i bet i've answered this before but i
don't want to be inconsistent i think i
said waffles
however you're feeling today i think i
like waffles
but i also like pancakes so
i don't really like this question moving
on are rose gold and gunmetal gray air
pods a good idea i mean yeah have you
seen
yeah yep they're sitting in my doorstep
right now really i'm so excited i'll
show you the ones i have they're matte
red and matte black
but that's probably not the best idea
for like an airpod you want something
that like hides dirt better yeah
but they're amazing i would be totally
down with new airpod colors i would be
too what is it what is the next iphone
called
i was going to ask you the same thing i
have no iphone
because there's supposed to be a small
iphone 10 i'm just going to call it
iphone 10 a small one and then like a
bigger iphone 10 and then like an even
bigger iphone 10 and then the two bigger
ones are oled the smaller one is lcd but
the smaller one with lcd has different
colors than the big ones that are oled
this is even overwhelming for me don't
even know where you begin to name these
things i don't know i mean would it be
but iphone 11 would be weird because
they skipped nine which still i'm a
little sassy about and then they picked
a roman numeral for one and a number for
the other and i still want to call it x
and i try really i still everyone's
going to call it xy
so what do you
this is a this is one of the biggest
mysteries in tech today what is the next
iphone gonna be called who's better at
fortnite
do you play i mean yeah then you're
better than me okay all right
yay did you get the four terabyte
yeah yeah i did people were
it's the most expensive option it's 3
000 i that's an entirely new computer
it's a lot more than most people pay for
a computer by itself but here's the
thing about having all that much storage
i know it's it's way overpriced but
cloud storage is great but like when you
work with big files
you just need
a big drive that's true someone said did
you perfectly make this an open for a
surprise tweet because it shows up like
that in the timeline and then you open
it and mac appears that's so good didn't
do that on purpose did not do it on
purpose i mean yeah totally did that on
purpose gotcha of course i'd be curious
for your answer this what is your
favorite smartphone to date
favorite smartphone is it automatically
the iphone 10. because it's the latest
and greatest or was there like a
nostalgic like
5s or like se i mean i probably maybe a
red one even just the first iphone i
feel like that was such a revolutionary
time i think for all of us and for me
personally because i didn't know what i
was gonna do for the rest of my life i
was confused everything so it's like
when i got that phone it just felt like
i was
now connected to everything and then it
just sort of became like my storytelling
device it's like a milestone type of
device yeah that's fair i think my first
phone ever would be one of my favorites
it wasn't the best phone i ever owned
but it was the motorola droid
it had those droid does commercials
there's just the whole whole culture
around it that was really exciting for
me at that time so i'll put that high on
my list what was your first iphone
wow i think 5s
5s was the first iphone i ever owned and
actually the first time i ever held a
first gen iphone was yours yeah so i had
never been close to that that was the
that was the i think that was that the
iphone 10 yeah oh my goodness it is
crazy just to hold it now because it is
it's it's like it is a nice size though
so it's a nice little brick phone yeah
yeah have you done that have you had to
sleep outside i've never camped really
i've never done it you should do it just
for fun the closest i ever came was an
android phone actually really believe it
or not in hoboken there's a verizon
store and when i was a freshman in
college i
woke up early and got in line for the
verizon samsung galaxy nexus
and how long did you have to wait and i
was like 10th or 11th in line and waited
for
half an hour
that's it yeah
i mean because they just got people in
and out people were just buying the
phone it wasn't a whole thing nobody had
cameras but that was the only phone i've
ever physically waited in line for have
you waited in line for anything else
i don't think so really i mean other
than like a roller coaster that's
probably
never to never to buy anything i don't
think i waited it was over 24 hours for
the first playstation 2.
that was i was in college i think then
and then worth it well i didn't have a
job i was in college and then some woman
offered us 2 500 for it and i was like
oh okay here we go this is this is the
rest of the year i'm set nice and then
16 hours for the first dunk of donuts in
los angeles
and then 55 hours for the iphone 6.
all right so that's where i'm gonna end
this q a thank you for for asking your
questions and if you want to see a video
that was shot on justine's channel i'll
put a link after always remember it's up
here
where we will be exploring some other
tech
and i'll link it below in description
anyway but subscribe to justine if you
haven't already subscribed here do that
too thank you for watching yay catch you
guys in the next one
peace